اكثر من 100 شركه يابانيه مصنعه للمواد
الغذائيه والمشروبات رفعت اسعار ما يزيد
على 20 الف منتج حتى نهايه اكتوبر تشرين
الاول الماضي وثم التوقعات باحتمال تطبيق
زيادات اخرى في الحد من تاثير تهاونين على
ايرادات وارباح تلك الشركات اما الاسره
اليابانيه فوجدت نفسها تحت وطاه تاكل
قدرتها الشرائيه بسبب انخفاض العمله
والتكلفه المتزايده للضروريات اليوميه
قناه منزل ابحث عن ارخص الاسعار للمواد
الغذائيه بهدف التوفير لكن لم يعد الامر
ممكنا ان الغلاء وصل الى كل المواد
والمتاجر
بدات العمله اليابانيه خساره قيمتها منذ
اثار مارس الماضي ليقفز سعر صرفها من 215
حتى تجاوز 145 دينار مقابل الدولار تحديدا
في 22 من ايلول سبتمبر حيث اتجهت الانظار
الى بنك اليابان المركزي الذي ابقى على
سياسه التسهيل النقدي الفائقي دون تغيير
لتبقى اليابان الدوله الوحيده في العالم
التي تطبق اسعار فائده سلبيه
اما اليوم فتلجا الحكومه الى ملابسها
الاخير وهو التدخل في سوق العملات هدف بنك
اليابان من سياسته ودعم الاقتصاد بعد
جائحه كورونا بالتزامن مع ارتفاع اسعار
السلع الاساسيه في بلد موارده فقيره
العام القادم وتوقعوا ان يقوم خلفه
بالتخلي عن السياسه الحاليه ليعاود
الارتفاع
والسياحه فتراجع الين يعزز قدره التنافسيه
للصادرات ويجتذبوا مزيدا من السياح
لكن تظل هذه المكاسب الجانبيه
رهنا بنمو الاقتصاد العالمي وتاثير رفع
اسعار الفائده في جميع انحاء العالم على
كبح جماح التضخم
تندرج السياسه المتعلقه بالنقد الاجنبي
ظاهريا ضمن اختصاص وزاره الماليه لكن
التدخلات الاخيره لانقاذ الين اكدت ان
الحكومه ستلعب دورا اساسيا في التعامل مع
تقلبات العمله والتخفيف من تداعيات التضخم
مهامه سمراء الجزيره طوكيو